foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John deloney show one of our more
popular shows these days on the Ramsay
networks so be sure you check all that
out he's my co-host today open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Kirsten is
going to start this hour off in Fresno
hi Kirsten how are you
good what's up
passed away in the past year oh I'm
sorry I have thanks I have three
siblings sorry I'm nervous that's okay I
have three siblings that um
and I that uh my parents had left the
house to us in the trust and it's just a
little awkward now because
I had been taking care of my my parents
and living with them for the past five
years so this is the house is where I
live also and
um I
am just trying to figure out how I can
um split up the house without
um having to sell it or move out because
it's really the most affordable thing
that I can afford right now since I've
been working just part time taking care
of my parents and then how long how long
have your parents been gone honey
so sorry yeah yeah
so it's been six months
yeah so what are your career plans
well
there's some designer and I'm trying to
well I am getting my portfolio together
and looking for you know a more a bigger
paycheck and so that will help but when
I'm sorry when
um you know you haven't been taking care
of your parents for six months
months since your dad's been gone yes
and your heart is broken
but when are you gonna get a job
well I have had my part-time job but I
am looking for
my previous career job for six months
um I haven't really started I thought
until yeah the past month well the past
week yeah
yeah the greatest way you can honor your
mom and your dad
was to have given them what you gave
them which is your time you're the one
that took on the role as a caretaker
it's an Incredible Gift
the next way you can honor your mom and
dad is to truly live and cherish every
minute you got left and you can't do
that when you're worried about not
eating and not working and you're gonna
have to take on the responsibilities
this shoulder the responsibilities and
what you're going to find is when you
start carrying that weight your body's
designed for that yeah it's so great and
the reason I'm asking all this is if you
buy this house from your siblings you've
got to be able to afford to pay it and
right now you can't
yeah so I got I gotta I gotta work
backwards into a job that's why I
started there and that's why I pushed on
you so hard because I love you and I
want you to win okay so what is the
value of this house
um probably about 350. okay is it paid
off
no
what's up what's out on it 178
okay all right and
um
do any of them want it
no they all have their own houses and
two and there's three others there's
four of you correct yes four of us okay
so each of there's not a big bunch of
money gonna come out of this you
understand that 25 or 30 000 bucks a
piece yeah okay and
um
so uh if you were to land a good job in
the fashion industry what do you think
you'll be making
um probably at least 80 a year okay all
right good
um well I mean you could go and get a
home equity loan and buy them out
there's enough equity in the house keep
the First Mortgage in place just keep
paying it and then go get a home equity
loan and buy them out there's nothing
wrong with that plan
um but the thing that is wrong with that
plan is you can't do that now because
you don't have any income you can't even
pay the first mortgage right now how
you've been paying the first mortgage
for the last six months well my parents
uh oh they left some money yeah and she
had an insurance
um a mortgage insurance that would pay
for 10 months so the mortgages
definitely paid for 10 months so there
is a train coming at you through the
tunnel that you are ignoring
yeah you need more urgency on getting
your income going
right
uh because if you don't they're you're
gonna lose his house yeah
I'd get a full-time job get my portfolio
together in the evenings and on weekends
yeah tomorrow I'd go get a job full time
yeah and then I'd get another job and
then I'll get another job I think you
need to be working all the time and I'm
going to tell you something wild you're
gonna find healing in those little not
to quote Dave but to quote Dave those
little baby steps of achievement and
accomplishment you're gonna find Healing
there yeah so I think you can buy them
all out and the way you do it is you
take the current value of the property
times 80 percent because that's about
what they'll net
minus minus the mortgage and divide it
by four and that's going to put you at
about 25 000 bucks and so you need about
seventy five thousand dollars to buy
them out and the second a second
mortgage HELOC will do that if you've
got a good job you can get that yeah and
then you transfer the property into your
name out of the name of the trust and
you buy them out if that's what they
want to do but that's all they're going
to get if you guys all just gang up and
sell it which also by the way Kirsten is
an okay idea it's not a bad idea to sell
this house before you screw around and
lose it be sure you sell it yeah don't
let it slip away because we're just I
would definitely do that if it came to
that well it has come to that you have
three months before this insurance Runs
Out
I mean this there's a fire here
you know I don't sense you
are I don't sense any urgency in your
vocal responses yeah it's almost a
numbness to the whole thing yeah the pro
hear us say as much as we love you
this doesn't go away no it's gonna get
worse every day taken from you every day
every day you're gonna get more
desperate and you know who sells real
estate super cheap desperate people
that's a giveaway property and rich
people come buy it and do well and get
richer right because they're not
desperate so Dave the the tactically
how would you
would you have to go through a real
estate agent to split this up because I
want to do it in writing you just have
to go get an attorney and have the title
title transferred to her uh with a with
a quit claim deed from the trust to her
and in order for that to happen her
siblings have to sign off and they get
25k a piece at that table where they
sign off because you got to know you
gotta know you've set up a a simple home
equity loan and so you know you got 75k
on top of 180k so 255
000 out on a 350 000 house that's not
bad that's not a bad situation it is a
bad situation if you're unemployed
that's important part of this equation
y'all this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsay personality is my co-host
today the question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services spring is here and neighborly
can help keep your home and yard in top
shape with the ground Skies mosquito Joe
Lawn Pride Molly Maid and more so spend
time enjoying your home not working on
it go to neighborly.com and find the
service pros in your area all right
today's question comes from Clark in Los
Angeles Clark writes we have three
thousand six hundred dollars in our bank
account but my wife wants to join a
six-week MLM training course for ten
thousand dollars
it's her way or the highway on this she
was approved for a five thousand dollar
credit card and she applied for a two
thousand dollar loan with our bank
the deposit on the course is three
thousand dollars which she would take
from our checking leaving us with 600
bucks in the bank then there's the
payment plan
she's already been doing MLM for four
years which we have made zero profit on
am I crazy to be mad about her on this
matter I need your help
Dave I'm actually mad for Clark
like it's frustrating
it's frustrating this is somebody who's
out of control
yeah
yeah it is it's out of control
and
the the
one of the most aggravating things about
people that get into mlms not everyone
but but but some people to get in it
they take on this cult-like
thing to wear if you're not in it then
you must be stupid
and if you don't understand what I'm
doing then you're an idiot because only
people that are smart do I mean all the
smart people do this stuff and if you
don't understand and they actually some
of the mlms really some of the
hierarchies within certain mlms will
push that mentality we caught Mary Kay
about 15 years ago I don't know if they
still do it or not they were telling
ladies to uh use their credit card to
buy the stuff and not tell their husband
they're telling them from the stage to
lie to their husband yikes and I'm like
man that's some bad medicine right there
ladies you guys are you guys are freaks
this is nutty that's total greed run
amok well that's looking in your
checking account
you're
yeah sixty four hundred dollars off like
everything you've mentioned says that um
the the this entire plan is stupid okay
it's out of control and the but Juiced
up with a wife that says uh I'm doing
this because this is my way even though
there's absolutely no track record in
four years that she's ever made any
money doing it and there's no there's no
way to get this money
they might get this 2 000 loan but I
mean the exposure to the whole family
over this deal yeah and she's she's
putting everyone's putting aside Common
Sense she's putting aside good financial
decisions her marriage Fidelity aside
her uh her husband's wishes she's
putting aside the good of her own family
all for her to chase this greed and this
is greed
make no mistake oh yeah because this is
I'm going to do this and then I'm going
to be able to buy a yacht I'm going to
live the dream as the Himalayan people
say and so uh that that is straight up
greed and when you and when you push
everyone including Common Sense Good
Financial sense your husband's Wishes
the good of your family aside for your
selfish greed you are a mess you're a
hot mess lady yeah you're messed up so
now what does Clark do I think you guys
have got to see a marriage counselor I I
think instantaneously because I I always
tell couples man you be real careful
with
my way or the highway my way of the
highway because people choose a highway
that's exactly right and use that for
very very rare circumstances and um she
pulled it on an MLM training course
[Laughter]
that's a pretty big waste of that set of
ammunitions like being in Vegas and they
you're playing Texas Hold'em and they
give you a two and a six and you're just
like I'm all in like that's a bold move
with this
um so Dave just to just because Clark's
the only one we got here right yeah
she's not a part of this conversation
well if he has outlined it correctly
they got serious issues there's no
question they got serious issues this
also feels like a power play and
sometimes there's power plays because
people have lost their mind they're just
they're jerks they're nuts they bought
into something that is a cult and they
can't see the forest of the trees
sometimes people smash the other side of
the teeter-totter because somebody else
in the marriage has been holding it down
for so long and so long and so long and
so long and so Clark If that's you if
you have completely wrapped this house
up in this is my way of the highway and
she finally says enough this is my way
of the highway
um then that's something you need to put
on the table you might have a report
you've sown there you go but if not
brother I'm sorry
um I would go see somebody this week and
if she won't go you need to go by
yourself because it looks like y'all are
heading in completely different
directions yeah this marriage does not
last absolutely not without help nope
this does not help it does not last okay
because she's she's ready to burn the
place down
for a dream that has absolutely no
underpinning whatsoever
and um she ready to burn your family
burn you burn the finances burn
everything burn the marriage all over a
training course for MLM does that not
sound like the dumbest thing you ever
heard in your life I'm getting ready to
end every part of my life that's
positive for that that that let me tell
you if you're in an MLM and you're
recommending that your people downline
do that you should have your butt kicked
up around your neck and wear it like a
collar you really should have somebody
talk to you you're hurting people you're
hurting people you are a manipulative
unbelievable jerk and you've got to stop
that and you're the reason that people
hate mlms as people like you that do
that now actually no a few human beings
in mlms that are reasonable human beings
absolutely and they don't think I'm
going to hell because I'm not in their
MLM it's not a call you know they
believe in their products they believe
in their products and it's their method
of selling it and I'm not mad at them
that's not the point the point is that
the something about the MLM culture
generates ever so often a company or a
hierarchy within a company that promotes
this kind of crap
well it goes back to what I think it
makes me think of like Blockbuster they
made their money when their customers
lost they made their money on late fees
and they needed their customer to fail
so that they could make their money not
the other way around if you're teaching
people I lie to your husbands then you
are making your money off a marriage
that's going to fall apart you're making
money off deception you're making money
off hurting people and there will be an
end game to your business you have to be
about how can we help you not how can we
lie to you what's the Long play
absolutely how does everyone end up more
whole healthy and prosperous when we're
done otherwise your business will go if
it's not about helping people yeah so
I'll give you an example all right uh to
go to entree leadership Master Series
I think the tickets are gone for
platinum for uh April of next year okay
there'll be about 3 000 people there
there'll be some of the top speakers in
the world and teachers in the world I'm
very very proud of what we will be doing
but to sit in a platinum seat is just
under ten thousand dollars
if you call me up and you say the way
you're going to go
to platinum as good as Platinum is and
it might be in the Platinum experiences
and as good as Entre leadership Master
Series is might be the best leadership
conference in America today Bar None I
mean I'm so proud of what we do there we
just completed one so you've got high
marks on your screen when you're
speaking there's absolutely incredible
Dr Jordan Peterson Willie Robertson
we're there with us and Malcolm glad
while we're there with us it was an
incredible incredible event and we had
guys on the front row that paid almost
ten thousand dollars a piece to be
sitting there in that Platinum section
if you call me up and you say the way
you're going to come and sit in the
Platinum section at entree leadership as
proud as I am of it and as I know it's
worth every dime is that you're going to
clean out your bank account down to six
hundred dollars and you're going to go
against your spouse's wishes I'm going
to tell you I don't want you as a
customer and you're borrowing seven
thousand yeah you need to stay home
absolutely you know I do not want your
money
you need to stay home because I don't
want your marriage is blood online this
is not what I do right I don't do I mean
I I sell something like a ten thousand
dollar weekend is my point and never one
time have we knowingly accepted a
situation like this and encouraged this
is the way to get ten thousand dollars
out of somebody nope nope don't need the
money that bad boys and girls I gotta
sleep later
it's not that hard a life you know this
is just wrong so honey Clark get your
marriage counselor because when your
wife says my way or the highway on
anything this is known as a flare was
just shot up off the deck of the boat
warning warning and that boat is going
down this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
Hollow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you are here Tom is in
Greensboro North Carolina Welcome to the
Ramsey show Tom
how y'all doing thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
all right so I'm gonna get right to the
point
um I'm in financial peace I got every
dollar
um
but my dilemma is that I share custody
of my son my schedule allows me to have
him on the days that I'm off
but if I'm going to pursue getting out
of debt as quickly as I need to it would
result in me having to give up some of
those days
and that is the part that I'm struggling
with
how old is he
he's won
how long have you all been divorced
uh over a year
I'm so confused
so he's won and you've been divorced
over a year
so we we it happened all kind of at the
same time yes sir all right so about the
same timeline okay yes yes so we'll make
him the same age as the divorce okay
that helps me a little all right and so
um all right now uh uh
what do you do for a living
uh I drive a truck
over the road
uh no I'm local so you're working 40
hours
uh I well with overtime
um I'm looking at about
90 every two weeks
45 hours yes sir okay and
um how much debt do you have
um so total debt is
let's call it 27k it's 26 729 yeah and
what do you make now
um so my take home is 60k okay so your
typical day when you're driving truck
not when you're with your son you go to
work at what time
uh about 10 A.M
okay and you drive then until about 8 00
p.m 8 P.M yes sir yeah okay all right
that gets you here 45 hours all right
yes sir okay
what about
on the days you don't have your son
you're at 50 50 you said
yes so yes sir yeah what days of the
week
I'm sorry say that again what day of the
week is that
so we work on a two two three schedule
okay
um so it rotates every every week so
basically in the two week period I get
him seven days out of the out of that
two week period okay
um
and I'm just struggling with do I want
to give up one of my days and have a
babysitter or have a family member watch
him while I go and work if I was you
yes sir
I would be pretty intentional about
getting up at 5am on the days I don't
have to be until 10 and drive Uber and
Lyft in the morning
as well okay
um
that kind of tacks into the what is that
60k uh so it's Amazon Flex okay all
right so you're doing and you're doing
that in the mornings before you go to
work yes sir so in a strange way and
Dave you've done this longer than me on
this particular question
if this was inside your home
I would if you're if you and your wife
and your boy lived inside in the same
house I would tell you hit the gas work
seven days a week and get this 27 bucks
27 000 off your chest
the fact that this is broken up in this
way
with how rapid a one-year-old develops
six months of no dad
it's not that's not okay it's glaring
it's too much yeah I'm with you I'd
rather slow the roll on paying off the
debt and make sure I've got that time
with my son because that time is
precious what is the 27 000 in debt what
kind of debt
I knew he was gonna ask
um
so 20K that is car God Almighty sell
your car it's your kid I know no you
don't yeah you don't know because you
didn't you had to ask why'd you have to
ask and you didn't even want to tell us
because you knew we were going to say
what you already knew you should do it's
your kid
trade your car for a kid
yes sir so your stupid car this week
what kind of car is it Tom
to Honda Civic oh my God don't trade a
Civic for a kid for sure
Tom not even a really cool car I mean
come on yeah if it was like a Mercedes
well I mean if I mean not if it was a
you know vintage Camaro I mean give me a
oh my gosh no I'm not talking I'm
kidding around Tom but yeah
you got this figured out you just
thought through it get you a one
thousand dollar car
and take care of your one-year-old and
get your butt out of debt work and
you're working and live on beans and
rice rice and beans and do not miss a
single day that you have available for
this child he is the most important
thing in this conversation I will affirm
you as being a good dad you have a good
heart you are aimed at the right thing
you knew you needed to do that but you
were trying to make the math work and
keep the car and so we get to tell you
the classic Ramsay show line sell the
car
yes sir are you gonna do it yes sir good
how old are you Tom
I'm 32. and you're a good man this kid
hey this kid this kid's lucky to have
you as a dad
and here's what Dave and I are also
giving you in about 10 years he'll be
he'll be 11 he'll make you a real mad
and in a fit of rage you can turn and
stare him in directly in the eyes and
say I saw the car for you I gave up a
Civic for you
and then he'll be like seriously and
you'll be like yeah yeah that didn't go
then it goes as hard as I thought it was
going to not much of a flag shot
I thought that was going to go way
harder than it did man
I gave up a Civic I just don't think
that could leave your mouth wow Dad I'll
let the school counselor know next time
we meet
[Laughter]
sell the Civic brother
oh Tom you're a good guy I appreciate
your question Tom you're awesome brother
yeah here's the thing folks um
very seldom are we as boxed in and
trapped as sometimes we feel like we are
uh because sometimes there's a simple
thing you can throw a stick of dynamite
right in the middle of it blow it up and
you go oh well look at there and you
know there it is
oh that's so great but I do think it's
important if if there's a you're in the
household together and you're not making
eye contact every day but there is
passing there is they see you every day
then I'm gonna tell you to go run and
get this thing done because the
long-term stress in your household is
not gonna be worth it that's stress
exists but in that case I would sell the
car too a hundred percent yeah if I'm
worried about it
if I'm worried about being there for my
one-year-old a hundred percent I'm not
trading a car for that there's not a
circumstance no not at all no not at all
not happening
uh John's in Portland Maine hey John
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
sure how can we help all right so I've
been listening for a while
um and love you guys the show my wife
and I have been doing really good at
paying down everything
um we owe right now about 171 thousand
dollars
um and 115 000 of that is on a mortgage
in the house we live in
and 56 000 is my student loans which
I've actually paid down from a hundred
eighty thousand dollars good job John
yeah man that's awesome so we're at the
point now where we don't owe anything
else we own our cars we own everything
else we just we have about 300 000
um not in equity in the house we live in
but that's what it's worth now with 115
000 balance um and we actually paid off
um a rental property that we owned two
years ago when I opened my own business
and tripled my income
um so we're at the point where we've
been living our letting our grandmother
live there as kind of like a Mitzvah
like as a as a good deed and she's ready
to move out because she has dementia
unfortunately and the market is
fantastic obviously especially in Maine
um price values have gone up and are
staying here
um and we don't know if we should invest
a little bit of money into the property
and continue to rent it or to just take
advantage now how much is a little bit
of money
uh what's the property worth what would
you invest into it why does it need
investment
and what do you need to spend quickly
probably sixty thousand dollars no
it's not where you have sixty thousand
dollars in student loan debt yeah that's
what I was thinking it would take years
to get back what we could do if you
can't if you can't fix it up for a few
thousand dollars and get it going you
probably need to sell it but uh
otherwise I try to keep it because I
love the idea of keeping a paid for a
rental property and knocking out 56 when
you've had all this other success but if
the houses are going up people are going
to rent it we're not going to turn this
thing off that's been working and go
over and fix a rental house for 60k now
if you want to spend five or ten on it
you can probably pull that off and still
get your student loan paid off by
Christmas let's go do that keep the
rental but no not 60. this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Debbie is in New York hi Debbie welcome
to the Ramsey Show hi I have a quick
question for you I am the surviving
spouse age 72 of a Vietnam vet he passed
away 32 months ago with service related
injuries
um we had filed for the VA disability
benefits back in 2017.
I was documented proven submitted I did
it myself because no one was available
to help me it was denied but I appealed
and now it looks like I have won the
case however they're not coming through
with anything they said the claim is now
at our regional office in Buffalo New
York and that I would be receiving a
letter showing the VA money or the what
they call the VA rate with the rate of
disability and if additional benefits
were to come to me like medical dental
vision
Etc
um so I don't know what the amount will
be or if it will be I call them honestly
every week because I don't want to fall
through the cracks and I know I have to
keep on them they keep saying they are
back loaded because of the pandemic they
don't have enough support and I said no
you know it helps that back loading yes
whining nagging widows I love you you're
awesome
you are getting it girl I love you
that's what the man at the VA told me he
goes I can't do any more than you've
done because you are like a uh
yeah and I will not give up um
he died of congestive heart failure and
stage four kidney disease they lost the
records They found the records now they
tell me I'm top priority but they don't
know when it's going to come through
however in the meantime I have been
paying off our medical debts I'm down to
about fifty eight hundred dollars in
medical debts which I'm paying on my
Visa I do not owe any loans I have a
mortgage of about a hundred and thirty
four thousand dollars
um I I guess my payment's about Eleven
Hundred uh my pension from my husband's
about 1100
um his Social Security is 2703 and I owe
no other debt what I wanted to know
should I take from the 401 he has about
170 000 in the 401 to pay off the
mortgage and the remaining five thousand
dollar Visa or should I just keep um
keep the money under 70 and the 401 and
yes and the uh mortgage is how much
about 134 135 000 that's the balance
so leaves you almost broke doesn't it
exactly by the time they take out taxes
then it'll put me in a higher tax from
my county and school taxes what's your
um
house worth
house is worth I would guess probably
around 275.
[Music]
I can't afford
living um let's just say I can't go on a
cruise like the other lady who called in
with my niece or anything like that but
I can't I can't go on vacation right now
I'm I'm making it but it's not really
I'm existing I'm not really living I'm
existing they did promise some type of
income but again it depends on the rate
of disability let me tell you what is
bothering me okay sure
I love the idea of you having not not
having the house payment
I hate the idea of you having no money
okay you got 170 000 bucks right now so
that's what's bothering me so what ends
up happening is if we say all right
let's cash this out pay the taxes and
pay off the house
and you got almost no money I mean 10 or
15 20 000 bucks is left over Max okay
right and um but you're 100 Dead free
and you've got these streams of income
to live on all you got to do is pay your
property tax and your insurance and your
groceries and your lights and you get a
life right that all works good but if an
event happens
that's a thirty thousand dollar event
you got no money
right
and you you're probably selling the
house if that happens
[Music]
do we want that risk
no okay I might be okay with that if you
said yeah I'll just sell it and get me
an apartment if some if I don't think
anything's going to blow up but if
something big blew up and I had a
hundred thousand dollar problem I just
sell the house and get me an apartment
gone but you should know really fast
right right there's nothing around this
area that you can live in my
apartment
but the um
but however if they do come through with
a monthly income it could be anywhere
maybe they're saying maybe 1500 but
they're not sure depending is there any
money that they would owe you in a lump
sum back for having not paid him his
disability for a number of years that's
what they're trying to figure out this
should go back to 2017 but now with the
pack back that was installed last August
it may it go back only maybe uh nine
months which would still be a decent
amount for me to pay off the Visa and
just have my mortgage yeah that would
that that's a good move right there for
sure we're doing that one but if they if
you got like 30 000 bucks
that might swing this then I might pull
the 401K because at least I'm not down
to I'm afraid you're gonna end up with
10 or 15 20 000 bucks when all the taxes
are paid the house was paid off and the
Visas paid off and then then you have an
event happen that's five or six thousand
dollars more than you've got and we put
the house at risk because we kept no
cash to protect the house does that make
sense yes it does but if you've got a
lump sum from the back pay on the
disability of 30 grand then now I'm
starting to have a a 30 uh a thirty
thousand dollar uh or really a fifty
thousand dollar nest egg at that point
I'm probably paying off the house then
that helps me get there but I'm just
scared I don't want you to
yeah I don't want you have to dig up the
bushes if and eat them if you have if
you get the tight you know exactly are
you living on social social security
right now yeah I only had his when he
passed away I only received his now I
did have mine I work
I were able so I'm not able to go out
and get a job although I do side work on
the side I pet said I dog said I do
alterations so I'm making you know a few
hundred dollars a month just to keep my
you know the lights on as you said yeah
I I think I'm going to let it swing on
how big the the lump sum coming from the
VA is okay and then uh and you call me
back if we can help you okay hey you
want to go through Financial Peace
University on us you want us to pay for
it and you go through the class on how
to handle money would that help you oh I
would love that all right hey we're
gonna give it to you you hold on and
Scholar will pick up or whoever's in
there and um uh who's in there
um Jenna Jenna's in there I'm sorry I
can't see over the thing great so um
well it's just yeah and so uh anyway
she's gonna pick up and we'll get you
set up because you know one of the
things is people of Faith people of the
book the book tells us that we take care
of with us and orphans and so that's
what we do so and let us know if we can
help because that's a very tight
situation so and I'm glad you mentioned
that um
uh Dr Peter attia was on my show
yesterday one of those brilliant medical
minds and he one thing he talked about
was as you age
one of the most
unheralded unknown risks that outpaces
everything is falling
and my mom turned 71 she was just at a
gas station and it wasn't like her body
failed she just stepped off something a
little bit wrong and sheared her
shoulder off at the bone this is a year
or two ago but I love that you told her
that because she's going to look back on
her life this incredible woman who's
strong she's just bustling ahead
and adjust at 72 years old it takes one
inch wrong going up a staircase and you
end up with a thirty thousand dollar
forty thousand dollar broken arm and in
her case that wipes her out right if
they don't come through yeah
um there's just it's the risk is so much
more accelerated that way well and
you know from a financial standpoint
those of you out there that want to
learn the financial terms
having cash
you know we always we used to say when
we opened the show Cassius King dead is
dumb right
um having cash liquidity is the
financial term which always thought was
kind of funny but water but um liquidity
uh having some cash is a an insurance
policy against losing your home and
that's what we're dealing with there she
we were taking her to no liquidity
having no cash no no buffer that makes
me real nervous oh man it's making me
nervous just talking about it and it's
not even I mean it's just somebody I you
know one of our listeners that we love
but it wasn't me but I mean I can't the
idea of being cashless oh I wouldn't
like a big pile of cash I do I do it's
just something about it
because it just because it buffers you
against you know
all of a sudden a a crisis becomes an
inconvenience
when you have the money or it lets you
spread things out a little bit but if
it's all in your house and you got no
money now I got to sell my house because
I got a crush
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsey Way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
new work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phone is a triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money it is a
free free call Johnny's with us in Boise
Idaho hi Johnny welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey guys thanks for having me on sure
how can we help
um I'm a self-employed contractor uh on
46 my wife's 40. we don't have anything
saved for retirement
um we have an auto loan a mortgage
a little bit of credit card debt and uh
and we're just wondering what the best
plan moving forward is from here we have
about 110 in savings
okay so how much debt do you have not
counting your house
uh I have a truck loan that's there's
about 40 left on it okay and that's your
only debt other than your house
yeah a couple thousand in credit cards
but we usually pay that off every month
and you have a hundred and ten thousand
in Savings in cash
not counting retirement
I have no retirement there's no 401
nothing how old are you
I'm 46 and my wife is 40 and she's uh
she stays home she's not in the hood all
right and what's your household income
sir
um it varies but I would say it's
probably around 90 to 100. good okay
all right Johnny I get the sense from
the words you're using and the way you
ask this question that you're fairly new
to this whole Ramsay discussion about
money
I am yeah okay all right
um so our whole thing is when I was in
my 20s I went completely broke because I
was stupid and I went into debt up to my
eyeballs buying real estate and that
taught me a lesson that stuck with me
the rest of my life I'm now 62 so I've
lived 35 years with zero debt
okay that's awesome and that has given
me the control of my most powerful
wealth building tool which is your
income
and it's easy to visualize this if you
had no payments
and you were in control of your money
with a written game plan where you're
telling every dollar what to do you
could enjoy life and also invest
aggressively and not be broke
because you make good money
that makes sense okay yeah absolutely
because your your car payment is is what
800. uh it's about 750 yeah almost like
I've done this before yeah okay yeah
right all right and so 750 and see if
you invest 750 a month from your age
until retirement you'll be a millionaire
that's awesome that's what I want yeah
you got 20 years
so you you'd be a millionaire and so but
but instead you got car payments
and no plan yeah no plan and you just
kind of wander along and go I got some
money saved but which you did a good job
110 000 in the bank you're way ahead of
most people right I mean that's pretty
impressive but but you kind of almost
you know I kind of almost fell into that
because it's not like you got some
detailed plan going I'm not picking on
you I just know you because I used to be
you is that okay
yeah that's that totally fine
understandable okay and so what we have
taught and what Sharon and I did after
we went broke is we got on a detailed
in-depth plan
and we became in charge of the money
making every dollar behave sometimes it
behaved for generosity sometimes it
behaved for investing sometimes it
behaves so we could have fun with it
all right okay and so then what we
discovered is again your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income so
if I woke up in your shoes what would I
do I would take some of the 110 000 I
pay off your car today
okay so my wife told me and then I would
get your credit cards out and I'd cut
them all up
okay and I'd pay them I know we pay we
use one mainly and then we usually pay
it off at the end of the month you know
what if you use a debit card on your
checking account it does everything your
credit card will do and the money comes
straight out of your account so you
don't have to pay it off at the end of
the month it already came out
what about the cash back advantage that
we get like the points we earned so far
it's not caused you to be rich
and by the way brother they're not your
friends so they're not hooking you up
with free money and flights every time
you use their card they're making their
money
you spend more money than you would
otherwise because you can just pay it
off later and it's psychological it's
just it's research in its data and it's
data and its data we don't tell you to
get rid of them because it's fun for us
we just look at the data man yeah so
when we talk when we talk to
Millionaires and we study researched
millionaires we find that they make
every dollar behave they're in agreement
with their spouse they quit borrowing
money and they invest and they're
generous and they pay off their house
and then they pay off their houses the
next thing so I'm gonna pay off I'm
gonna take 110 000 minus 40 which leaves
me 70. you make 90. so I'm gonna set
aside out of that 70 30 000 in a
separate high yield savings account
we're going to call that your emergency
fund and you never touch it even if you
have an emergency it's just sitting
there for really bad days
okay okay okay and then that leaves us
about 40 Grand doesn't it
it does yeah okay and uh we can do you
have children
I do I have three miners at home
um if anybody's going to college if
anybody's going to college you're gonna
need that 40 Grand
foreign
I'm not sure yet they don't know yeah
they're kind of younger still so well
let's let's talk to an investment
advisor about setting that aside for
them so you got an emergency fund you're
debt free I've used up your 110 you're
going to get on a detailed budget and
you're going to start putting 15 of your
household income away in a 401k or Roth
IRA we'll show you how to do every bit
of that Johnny if you want to do it I
can show you how to do it
um but what we're doing is is we're
going from I eat everything in sight
anytime I want to eat it and now I'm fat
and I don't want to do that anymore so
now I'm not going to eat everything in
sight and be fat because I did that I
ate every donut in a 50 mile radius
Johnny and I got fat as a hog just a
sloshing hillbilly hog it was awful and
so I had to quit eating everything in
sight because it didn't work for me you
know and I had to say okay I'm going to
actually take care of this body I only
got one and your money's the same way
you've got to make it behave you can't
be disorganized chaotic and impulsive
and end up anything but broke
and that's that's the thing so you're
not a you you really have done some very
good things in this process but uh dude
I'm getting ready to send you to boot
camp if you want to do this and you're
going to come out totally fit
and wealthy and if I had a punk rock
band
the first thing I would do in this show
is over I would call and say we're
changing our names to the sloshing
hillbilly Hogs
we would be incredible incredible well
Battle of the band's names here we go I
know I may I may have to change our name
that could happen right there
the sloshing hillbilly Hogs
didn't even know those existed did you
it's it's its own breed John yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I I think it's important to
call man
poor Johnny here was just doing what he
was told to do
I'm just doing it was told to do so bye
everybody everybody else normal people
I'm gonna get the normal get my points
I'm gonna save some money
I'm gonna get a big Supernatural always
gonna have a car payment
and I just worked my butt off and I have
nothing
and it'll kill you man it'll feel like a
rat in a wheel
hey Johnny hang on I'm gonna give you a
copy of the book The Total Money
Makeover the details out the plan I just
gave you and shows you exactly what to
do this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
hey guys how many of you thinking about
buying a house
but you're cringing when you think about
the debt for the rest of your life a
30-year mortgage is not your only option
now you don't have to fall in that trap
you can borrow and if you're going to do
it we don't recommend any more than a
15-year fixed rate uh it'll get you on
track to pay off your house fast and you
pay a ton less interest of course the
monthly payment is higher and scares
people off but you know what buy a
little less house you don't have to be
intimidated the free mortgage calculator
on our website can help it'll give you
an idea what your monthly payments would
look like could look like should look
like that way you'll know how much home
you can afford so you can be mortgage
free in 15 years or sooner
ramseysolutions.com click free tools and
you can use the mortgage calculator and
get confident about buying a home click
free tools
ramsesolutions.com Minnesota is next and
uh Devin is with us where is Alexandria
Minnesota Devin
I'm about an hour and a half uh
Northwest of St Paul Minnesota ah cool
okay hey did you hear the Vikings paid
off their Stadium
uh yeah that was the tobacco tax I'm not
surprised
okay cool how can we help
um I've got a 2015 Dodge Charger and I
owe 15 200 on it it is valued right
around 8 000.
I make sixty five thousand dollars a
year total income from my household
with bills and everything I'm right
around 3 600 a month I make about 3 800
a month
how do I get out of this car
you Mike how much a year
I'm salaried at 65 000 a year my at home
takes right around 3 800. what in the
world is coming out of your check before
it gets home at thirty six hundred
that's how they paid off the stadium
Dave
that's right no really no no I mean
three thousand dollars a month is coming
out of your check where is it going
uh I pay taxes and then
I guess I really haven't broke it down
other than I pay some child support
out of your check
yep pay 200 a month for child support
200 a month before you get the check
are your wages being garnished for back
pay
you know
okay are you paying okay
um did you get a huge tax refund last
year
yes we did and I've been listening to
your show for a few months how much was
your huge tax refund
eighteen thousand
I found it okay because I couldn't find
the two thousand dollars a month and
eighteen thousand dollar tax return okay
so here's how we fix your car problem we
go in tomorrow and change your W-2
withholding on your check by fifteen
hundred dollars a month
and that will mean you get zero tax
refund because 18 000 divided by twelve
is fifteen hundred
okay so you're going to bring home 1500
a month more and pay all of that on the
car and in 10 months the car will be
paid off
that makes sense ta-da
eighteen thousand dollars that is why I
called so yeah so the the the moral of
the story Devin is a tax refund is not
uh a gift from Santa Claus he does not
live in Washington DC the reason you're
getting a refund is you had fifteen
hundred dollars a month too much taken
out of your check and it sits in
Washington with no interest at the IRS
all year and then they send it back to
you in April after you file your taxes
and you think they did you a favor it
was your money all along
and so all I'm doing is putting your
money back to work for you
folks you should never get a tax refund
you should always adjust your tax
withholding to where you don't owe any
but you also don't get a refund 100 one
way or the other is the most it ought to
be off
you got to pay a hundred extra out of
your withholding or you got to get a
hundred dollar refund but you don't need
to be getting big refunds and for sure
it is not a blessing I'm old I am been
around I personally know Santa Claus and
he does not live in Washington DC
that's not where he comes from though
there are some old people in Washington
DC
there are some people desperate to
remain in Washington DC they're old for
I mean it's scary how that the the
mummification process in that town is
pretty amazing I think yeah I think I
think they put embalming fluid in some
of the local beers
well or you can buy it by the gallon at
the local plastic surgeon I'm not sure
which all right Jay this is whether it's
in Chicago hi James what's up
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help I'm so I'm selling my
current home and I'm scheduled to close
this month actually
um I'm also getting married in the next
month and building a home yeah and
you're building up in the south yep at
the same time good Lord lots of Life
yeah so we're also building a home in
the Southeast at the same time which
will be where we'll be starting our
family so we're actually waiting for
that to finish up before we move
um and then but so what I'm trying to
figure out is between my savings and the
profit from the current place that I'm
selling I'm trying to determine how much
I should put down on the new home
because I have quite a bit and I'm kind
of trying to go back and forth between
some of the things you say and throwing
as much as I can at the house and trying
to make that debt free as soon as
possible or taking some of that money
and putting it with my financial advisor
for them to invest it
yes well here's the thing I mean so you
already told me what I'm going to say
[Laughter]
the thing so no it's not no no it's not
no it's not you know exactly what we say
you were very clear on that so all
you've got to decide James is which of
these methods you think has the highest
probability of Building Wealth
okay
getting your house paid off as soon as
possible or borrowing on your house to
place the money with your tax with your
financial advisor
because effectively by not putting the
money down on the house you have
borrowed on the house
to put the money with a financial
advisor you understand that right
correct and so if you had a paid for
house would you go borrow on it to put
money with your financial advisor
because that's so smart that you're
going to get rich that way
obviously obviously you know I don't
think that
yeah and to your point I think my point
of view is I I think that
psychologically being debt free as soon
as possible I think if you take the
number of years I'll probably say 10
years from now I think the same amount
of money probably goes into the market
just once I'm as close to being debt
free that I'll be much more aggressive
um but I'll still have probably a 250
the 300 000 mortgage that I'll have to
pay off because it's it's not a cheap
house let's put it that way but uh how
old are you but but
uh 30. okay well I mean obviously James
you can do whatever you want you're like
a 30 year old man
so I mean do whatever yeah do whatever
you want but let me tell you let me tell
you that you're wrong and you called
here to ask and so the data tells us
when we talk to millionaires we talk to
ten thousand one hundred sixty seven of
them when we did detailed in-depth
research the larger study a
Millionaire's ever done in North America
the number of millionaires that we
talked to that said the reason I'm a
millionaire is I borrowed as much as I
could on my house I limited how much I
put down on my house so that I could put
the money with my financial advisor in
the market sooner and I carried a
mortgage was the net essence of this so
that I had more money in the market and
that money in the market and leveraging
and using my personal residence as a way
to get rich caused me to become a
millionaire the number of millionaires
that said that was precisely zero James
sure and here's my promise here's my
promise so you go with your plan or you
go with theirs my promise to you James
is this you're the guy who sold the
house got married and tried to build a
house in the same month good for you
you're a hustler you always have a
scheme and you always got a plan and a
plan and then a plan on top of that plan
that money that you think is going to be
in the market in 10 years won't because
your buddy in your new place will have
talked you into real estate properties
and you own a couple of duplexes because
you saw it on Instagram that money won't
be there
pay your house off and be free my
brother and then you can invest it's
whatever you want
to be looking for a shortcut be free the
fastest way to get rich quick is don't
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones are triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us America hey if
we all have people who tune in every
episode on this show right you know we
have people to do that like it's a
little shocking to me but they do and
we're happy for you we're glad you do
and we're thankful for you being there
but some people listen all the time and
they still feel stressed like you know
what to do but you want me to tell you
to sell the car
this is silly okay you don't have to do
this knowing what to do with your money
isn't the problem doing it is the thing
personal finance is 80 behavior only
twenty percent had knowledge and The
Proven way to change your behavior with
money is by taking a Financial Peace
University class the class is the
difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer
you'll have a coordinator that holds you
accountable encourages you other people
in the class pushing you and cheering
you on this is why the class has worked
for over 10 million people and after
nine weeks you will never handle money
the same way again you will make
progress faster than ever don't just
listen to the show commit to doing what
it takes to win join an FPU class at
ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com FPU Terry is in
Charlotte hi Terry welcome to the Ramsey
Show
thank you for taking my call and thank
you for what you do sir sure how can we
help
uh want to know what I need to do with a
pension plan for when I work for the
state of North Carolina and
um I'm 50 years old so I can start
drawing the actual tension if I need to
but I'm in the private sector now so I
don't plan on going back to the state
but they'll pay me a one-time payout of
a hundred and twenty six thousand
dollars if I take the one-time payout or
I can start drawing now for the rest of
my life twenty six hundred dollars a
month
or
if um I said it where it's I collect or
my wife collects or as long as either
one of us lives it'll decrease it by 180
so it'll pay twenty four hundred and
twenty dollars for as long as either one
of us live okay and she's 40 years old
or just for the fun of it I ran the
numbers and I could put my son who's
three years old in and they'll pay
2270 as long as me or him lives
hmm
well which way do I go with that yeah
well there's a thing called the time
value of money
would you rather have ten thousand
dollars today or would you rather ten
thousand dollars fifteen years from now
and the answer of course is today why
because you could invest it and it would
be worth a whole lot more than ten
thousand dollars fifteen years from now
so the 2200 that the three-year-old will
receive after your death is not 2200
it's two dollars
you follow me because it's so far out
into the future that it it doesn't it
doesn't create any real money so because
of the time value of money now the um
the normal answer the question equation
on this is take the lump sum and roll it
to an IRA in good growth stock mutual
funds now in your case the payout on
this is so high it's a very good payout
if you don't do that
that you probably won't make as much per
month
okay so if you make this if you make it
keep it Sovereign
Sovereign if I take the payout I only
get the money I paid in if the money
that the state pays into the pension I
only get that if I take the payout and
that's what makes the payout so much
better
yeah I know but uh yeah the payout but
the the solvent is the word you're
looking for but yeah the um but the the
the
but still so if you take 100 you say 130
000 is the payout the lump sum right
126 126 okay so 10 will be twelve
thousand dollars a year
one thousand dollars a month half
if you made 12 on your money
or ten percent of your money
um so which you know so you're gonna
you're gonna make half on the payout
which is unusual but that's because of
what you're talking about the state's
match portion they're not offering you
on the lump sum is there a point later
that the lump sum is better
um no it doesn't get better if I wait
till I'm 60 to draw it they'll pay me 3
200 a month from 65 or maybe 3 600 yeah
I wouldn't do that I would take that I
would take the draw now if you're going
to take the draw so here here's what I'm
going to recommend all right I would sit
down with a good investment professional
click smartvestor at ramseysolutions.com
you can find the who we recommend in
your area the smartvester pros and let
them crunch these numbers with you and
show you what you're dealing with
because basically if you took it and
rolled it to an IRA today and you were
to draw start drawing on it today which
you couldn't do but you would draw about
half of what we're talking about what
you would get if you just start taking
their draw which is a lot different okay
however
and depending on which scenario you
choose someday when someone dies this
pension goes away the hundred and twenty
six thousand dollars in your name is
always in your name regardless of who
dies when so it would go to your wife it
would go to your kid it would go to your
grandkid it would go to wherever it's
now in your name you don't lose it but
with a pension when you die or if you've
got the extensions when someone dies
it's gone
it goes poof okay so you gotta so
there's 126 000 swing not going poof
that also goes into the mathematics
it's not just the monthly compared to
the monthly
because if you leave it for instance
let's just say you leave it just for
your name and you take the full payout
just for Terry okay Terry dies the thing
goes poof right
right so you yes you got an extra
thousand dollars a month but yes you
lost 126 000 on your death
do I take the 2600 and then use part of
that money to go buy life insurance yeah
that's what you can do you could go the
other direction and that that would back
fund it that's exactly the right plan so
I think that's why I want you to sit
down with someone who's not sitting on
the radio trying to figure this out in
my head and work this with them because
what you've got is a very unusual thing
because the state 99 of the time I get
this question the payout is less than
you would get if you invested at your
the lump sum yourself
because most pensions are calculated on
a seven percent rate of return and you
can make eleven twelve percent in the in
a good growth stock mutual fund so
you're going to whip your pension on
terms of rate of return and you get more
per month and more if you die so it
almost always makes sense to take the
lump sum and roll it in your case what's
happening is the state you're losing the
state subsidy of it
and so that's doubling the payout if you
take the monthly thing so they're really
pushing you to do the monthly thing
they don't want you to cash it out that
math is telling us that so sit down with
a smartvester pro and crunch the numbers
and either backfill it with life
insurance and take the full pay I would
take the full pay just in your name and
then backfill the for your kid and your
wife with life insurance if you want to
buy some term insurance and um and then
reinvest some of that money don't don't
just consume it all
um you know if you reinvested all of it
now you got a really good plan just real
fast 2200 a month is going to become 126
000 in an investment real fast
yeah just putting the math looks excuse
me about five five and a half years yeah
catch that catch back up does that
include uh return that's just no dollars
a month that's just piling up the cash
at zero yeah interesting yeah yeah so
it's about a three year should be about
a three year turn really yeah and so
yeah that that's the uh but but for
those of you listening if you get the
opportunity to take a lump sum payout on
your pension almost always because of it
going poof on your death you come out
better off your family comes out better
off and you better off by Rolling it to
an IRA in good growth stock mutual funds
there's no taxes on it that way and then
uh and it does and it grows at a greater
rate and you don't lose it all when you
die I had never thought of this but I
can
I've been concerned about the solvency
of pension plans especially cities like
municipalities
I hadn't thought about this as a clever
out for them which is going to strongly
discuss it's just going to kick the can
down the road it's going to strongly
discourage people from taking a lump and
walking well I mean think about what it
does to our funds numbers if you're
paying out 2200 instead of 126 000. yeah
you can uh you go along you get your
annual bonus and go a long time so yeah
it helps keep them liquid and it helps
keep them stable on the on the balance
sheet side
love it love it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Daniels in
Pensacola hi Daniel how are you
how are you doing better than I deserve
how can I help
all right so I got a quick question I'll
try to get to the point here um
I'm in the military I serve the Navy in
here Pensacola I've been in for about 15
years
and I have a unique situation but I just
don't know how to go about it I want to
be intense but I want to be intense in
the right direction so
we just started the baby steps and me
and my wife and I after a few months
I've got her on board we're both heading
in the right direction and um
trying to knock off dead and things like
that and I'm trying to find ways to
lower expenses and increase income and
we've got the expenses down as low as
you can I'm trying to find ways to keep
doing that so now I'm thinking okay how
can I make more money
uh for obviously I'm the military so
making rank is one big one and um I'm
hoping to pick up Chief this year
um that'll be a big big increase in pay
for me but in the meantime I'm saying
those those results don't come out until
August
um so I'm like okay I need to think of
another job because I have a lot of a
lot of free time on my a lot of free
time here I'm gonna show you uh I'm
currently in school
and I've considered
uh drop uh getting getting out of school
or stopping School temporarily what are
you studying second job
accounting I'm going to school for an
accounting why
um
because once I leave the military that's
I'm retiring five years from the
military and I'm going to pursue being a
CPA
um that's a good plan the Navy's paying
for all that right now and so that's
what I want to do when I get out and so
your question is quitting school
uh yes to pick up a second job no
it no stay in school brother it's free
no get it it's free it's a good degree
don't give up the long term for the
short term
if you can give up the short term for
the long term that's always a good trade
how much do you owe brother
we're about 80 grand in debt right now
um and is it just haunting you do the
numbers what do you owe the money on it
is because
uh some consumer uh some credit cards
which uh I cut up and that's a truck a
truck payment we have one paid off car
and one one truck that is uh we owe on
the truck
it's at 49 and I I looked into selling
it to get rid of it and we can get about
maybe 37 on it and I was so frustrated
because I was getting ready to get rid
of it no I think you can get more than
that I think that was trade-in value the
CarMax offered you and I think you can
sell that truck for 40 and you need to
sell it
go down to a credit union and get them
to get a loan on the difference
and you cut your debt from owing 50
Grand to 41. or no it was 80 wasn't it
80 grand yeah yeah 80 grand sorry yeah
you get rid of half your debt over half
your debt and yeah definitely a big
relief yeah absolutely okay and then you
keep working on the accounting is your
long play
it was a good long way I'm retiring in
five years yeah yeah it's your long play
Don't destroy the Long play for a
short-term gain uh that that's
um no don't do that I appreciate your
hustle man you're turning over every
Rock You Got you're thinking you're
thinking with the right level of urgency
and I appreciate that for sure I agree
with John
um yeah that's that's not the way to go
I get rid of the truck I make Chief and
keep working on your accounting degree
and you're going to plow on through this
so what is your household income today
um so my wife has got on board and
helped he's been helping me out by
myself I bring you roughly 75 000 a year
and what are you gonna how much of a
bump do you get how many thousand a year
extra do you get if you make cheap and
cheap in August
uh
it's gonna be roughly five to six
hundred a month
so six or eight thousand a year okay
yeah pretty cool um and what does your
wife do
my wife she she homeschooled my children
at home um but she did pick up a gig to
stay close by in the neighborhood and
she's been helping me bring in about 15
18 100 a month
uh nannying for military wives who or
for military couples around our area who
who need the nanny jobs and their next
door neighbors across the street she's
got people all in the neighborhood I'm
like wow nice work and so yeah helping
out with bringing some extra cash I know
I'm waiting into
um treacherous Waters here so
YouTube people keep your comments to
yourself but brother if I was gonna make
a sacrifice right now
I might consider putting my kids in a
local school and my wife working
full-time and let's squash this thing in
12 months and be done sell the truck for
sure sell the truck
make go get a full-time job put the kids
in a local school and then let's
reconvene in 12 months because you'll
have cut your debt almost in half by
selling this truck and then between your
eighty thousand dollars you're gonna
pick up you pick up that extra money in
a few months man plus she's making 35 to
45 to 50. man you can get this stuff
knocked out quick yeah that'd be a short
a short play wouldn't be a long play but
um yeah uh thank you for your service by
the way
if you don't do that and she keeps
nannying and picks up more and kicks it
from 18 000 a year up to 25 000 a year
that'd be a big help you make chief that
adds another six or eight thousand
that's a big help
um and you get rid of the truck boom
you're gonna be done in 12 months
so if you really continue to lean into
this and I what I most appreciate about
your question and your approach Daniel
is is you're actually thinking about
this and you're willing to do just about
anything and there's an importance
um in the military the Berserker mode is
good but you got to be wise about going
Berserker man don't go so bananas that
in seven months you've just created a
quagmire yeah you're getting there man
good for you get your end away Mass some
SMS SMS Davis is with us in Grand
Junction Colorado hi Davis how are you
good Dave
what's up
um it's a quick question so uh we have a
pay for condo that we're living in right
now
we purchased another house and we're
going to be moving into it in the next
month
excuse me and then uh we're wondering if
we should pay or sell the condo to
put on the mortgage of the new house yes
or keep it as a vehicle rental yes
you should sell the condo
you know how I did that so fast
if you were sitting in your house one
day and you said I'm going to go borrow
more on my current residence to buy a
rental condo
you would never do that
no sir same difference
just reverse the process
okay yeah I don't mind rentals I don't
pay but I pay cash for them after my
after my residence is paid for so if
you're sitting on a paid for house or a
largely paid for house you don't go
borrow money against it and buy rentals
don't you that would be dumb even if you
pay cash for the rental because you
borrow it on the house
it's not cash but it's displaced debt
but yeah replaced today but Instagram
says I have to have a rental home
or I'll be poor forever Tick Tock says
that you can have 57 million dollars of
rental homes
and be 26 and have no Mortgage Debt I or
you don't have to pay a penny and all
because the renters pay everything
because renters always pay right on time
and they never tear up anything and
there's never been such thing as a one
to two year pause some people having to
pay heating and air unit on the rental
house never goes out and roofs are
perfect especially if it's an Airbnb
because we all know
that if you're on Tic Tac that you're
doing airbnbs because everyone knows
this is what rich people do
you guys are hearing the sarcasm font
right
it's frustrating man here's what's
frustrating it's it's predatory get rich
quick is human nature there's been a
version of it for 35 years I've been
doing this show there's always someone
pitching get rich quick of some kind
somewhere and a new digital
methodologies and social medias only
give it a new place for this cancer to
grow
and uh it just doesn't work just doesn't
work boys and girls there used to be
just to be that one person at your
church that chased you around trying to
get you to join in now if I'm looking
down real estate you click on it a few
times that's all you will see all day
every day 24 7 365 until you find the
cave
Hey listen start watching cute dogs on
Instagram and the more you watch it the
more it'll feed you cute dogs
it's better than watching nothing down
real estate morons you know what I'm
going to talk to a buddy who's a
researcher I want him to run that study
just I wanted to get 100 people that
just watch cute dogs that's all they are
allowed to look on there's some funny
dogs real funny yeah once you watch one
they'll send you another one and once
you watch one on nothing down real
estate they'll send you two more morons
on nothing done real estate in case
you're wondering there is moments when
we're walking through Ramsey Solutions
building and Dave's in the corner just
laughing to himself scrolling cute dogs
that little dog photo that's it that's
right you know that's happening y'all
can just see that can't you this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth to work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Genesee
is with us she is in Springfield
Illinois hi Genesee how are you
hi I'm doing great how are you better
than I deserve what's up
hi
um so I am a fresh new baby graduate
um and I'm about 217 000 in debt
um both of my parents didn't go to
college so I don't really have anybody
to talk to about like loan repayment and
things of that nature
um I did luckily get gifted your course
um from a Facebook group that I'm in and
I'm on step two but I'm wondering
um as I saw I'm a single parent
um I'm 26 and she's 10 I had her at 16.
and I just did School straight through
so no working in between High School
undergrad and then I just graduated from
veterinary school oh wow I have my
doctorate wow good for you good for you
thank you very much I'm just wondering
how realistic it is you know because it
seems like I'll never get to step three
with that much debt and I know I like I
said I'm on step two in the in the
course and I see a lot of like married
couples we work with a lot we work with
a lot of veterinarians
um in entree leadership because a lot of
them come through to learn how to run
their business the business aspect of
being a veterinarian and so what we're
what I'm discovering just in having
conversations with them is that there
are veterinarians
um working in a practice that don't own
the practice
lots of them that are making a hundred
and a quarter a hundred and a half
um there are a whole group of them too
that are making 60.
and 70.
um and so uh you know what I would tell
you is don't get too caught up in
a certain
area of veterinary medicine get caught
up in the area that can make you the
most money for a little while
I so I've actually signed on
um to a practice it is a corporate
practice so I don't own it and I don't
have any stake in it I start Monday
actually okay and
um this is going to be 100 105 000 a
year ding ding sounds like my
information's accurate okay and you'll
be going up pretty quick in that that's
just your starting and so you'll be at
100 and a quarter within a short period
of time so I'm pretty close all right
and you're used to living on nothing
yeah because you've been a college
student your whole life
yeah
yeah okay so so if you lived on nothing
what would how much is nothing
um my my rent at my house that I was
living in um from in my vet school was
about 5 50. I was one of five roommates
um and then my mom was helping me with
my daughter at that point in time
um so now when I move I've moved back to
my hometown
um my rent the rent here is pretty
insane it's going to be about for me to
rent and not you know have a mortgage
rental homes and rental apartments are
looking about 1200 1100 to 1200 a month
okay and then you know that's fourteen
thousand out of 105.
okay then we gotta eat we gotta eat and
we got to pay lights and we're not gonna
go buy a car on payments
yep I have I have a car I've owned it it
is on its last leg you're a veterinarian
just prop the leg up
all right and then
yeah and then
the expenses and then
so here's here's what I'm saying all
right 50
55 000 a year minus taxes is the most
you can spend to live
the other fifty thousand goes on your
debt and in four years you're done
okay so you think it wouldn't be worth
signing up for like an income based
repayment why would you want to stay in
debt the rest of your life
I don't okay let's get out of debt in
four years
okay just sooner okay I'm talking to a
woman who at the age of 16 with most
people
are trying to figure out how a blinker
works on their mom's car
had a child
and you have managed to be a mother and
a daughter and a graduate student and
now a veterinarian
making a hundred and five thousand at 26
years old you cannot sell me on the fact
that you can't quote unquote do
something you can do anything I would
fight you for them all the money in the
world
my friend Jade warshaw who's also caused
this show her and her husband had almost
half a million bucks and they did not
have veterinarian in their holster
they were music students and they did it
here's what's going to be frustrating
for you
you have been waiting for this moment
for so long and you're Dr Genesee now
and that car is going to stay the same
and that lifestyle is going to stay the
same and that 10 year old kid that you
promised just wait just wait just wait
three more years to go now they gotta
wait
because it's gonna take you four years
it's gonna take you three to four years
to do this and you can also work shifts
on Saturdays and Sundays and maybe even
uh do emergency medicine overnight if
you need to and let your kids stay with
your mom every once in a while if you go
pick up another 50 Grand doing that you
can be out of debt in two and a half
years
okay so it doesn't seem unattainable you
can't do this here's the big math okay
take 200 000 and divide it by the number
you're gonna put on it a year
I'll put 50 a year on it out of your 105
a minute ago then Sean added some work
to your life and we put another 40 or 50
on it
so 50 a year into 200 is four right
right this is attainable
and by the way this is not static you're
not going to only make 105 for the next
four years
and the extra income you're not going to
only want to do that forever so but if
you go made another 30 or 40 000 bucks
and now we put 80 on this you know what
is 200 divided by eighty three
not even okay two and three quarter
right okay
you following me here okay it's a big
number math you don't have to do you
don't have to have a master's degree in
math and finance to pull this off you
just divide 200 by the amount you're
going to throw at it and that tells you
how many years it's going to take for
you to get this done you're going to get
it done very very quickly and here's
underneath the math
my mom I've told the story on the show
my mom at 42 the age of 42 took her
first community college class one class
and it was either geometry or algebra
one of the two we took it together I was
I was in high school
fast forward to 57 is when she graduated
with her PhD and she became a tenured
professor at 63 and I'm and she teaches
her last year at Oxford this summer in
in her 70s
I tell you that to tell you I had a
ringside seat to a mom who completely
transformed her life and it was hard and
she was busy and she had to miss games
and she was working on Saturdays and
Sundays writing papers and reading and
doing grad school work
and as an adult she took away every
single excuse I could ever have because
I got a ringside seat to watch and a
gangster be born and so your son is
gonna watch you and you're gonna feel
guilty I want you to think of the long
game he's going to watch his mom teach
him through action he can do anything
he's married to I mean his mom's a
warrior princess it's incredible you're
giving him the gift of us of a lifetime
yep
way to go proud of you good work
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey guys if you like this
show and a bunch of you apparently do
because you've been helping us thank you
share of the show
click the share button or the share the
link depending on where and how you're
listening subscribe or follow if you're
on YouTube or Spotify or apple podcast
or let people know if you're listening
to talk radio or watching us on TBN let
people know that we're here and share of
Apple are we going to do a virtual
reality
headset Ramsay show a what headset
what are you talking about I forgot your
TV is still black and white never mind
no they had like uh they announced their
new VR headsets oh oh oh those things oh
yeah
apple announced theirs yesterday it's
not a headset it's an Oculus what's
wrong with you well I live in the woods
so there we go so no we're not I saw
James wearing ski goggles this morning
and I thought that no you didn't yeah
apple announced their new version
recently okay all right yeah yeah we're
I was trying to make the show sound
trendy and I just sounded dumb so there
you go America way to go worked out well
for you and uh yeah yeah and well you
got a couple of trogle diets here trying
to figure this out but the uh uh
we're like a far sidecar so I think I
think that means we're not doing it
that's what I think I'm gonna go with a
no on that one yeah that's a no the
stock market's been all over the place
lately it's gone up and gone down and
then back down and you're freaking out
don't Market dips don't mean you have to
retire broke uh you got to keep a
long-term perspective look at all the
facts if you invest 100 a month from age
25 to age 65 you'd have around a million
dollars at retirement no that's not too
good to be true that's based on what the
long-term average of the S P 500 is
and a huge predictor of investing
success is not the rate of return
but that you actually invest and you
keep investing so no matter how old you
are no matter how much you invest in
investing intimidates you you can invest
with confidence and you get a pro in
your corner to do it a pro helps you
with the heart of a teacher so you start
to understand what's going on because
most of your freak out is just from lack
of knowledge
and you don't have to get a master's
degree in finance you just gotta have
somebody in your corner go hey dude this
is how this works hey so we can connect
you with a smart investor Pro they each
sleep and breathe Investments and
they'll take the time to teach you to
work with you so you understand what you
are investing in go to
ramseysolutions.com smartvestor and find
a smartvestor pro today
ramseysolutions.com smart investor
Carolyn or Karen rather I'm sorry is in
Vermont hi Karen welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thanks for thanks for being willing
to talk to me sure what's up
so
um four months ago today my husband
passed away oh Karen I'm sorry
thank you Karen what happened oh
he was very sick for a long time just
about a collection of
oh my
how old was he
um this past weekend was
his birthday oh man it's what birthday
71st 71st what was his name
Danny
Denny
Danny Danny awesome okay I'm so sorry
honey how can we help you
um so I am working like a dog
um
just trying to have gotten a lot of debt
taken care of since he passed while our
mortgage caught back up and we're two
months behind
so that's done I'm a month ahead now on
our budget my budget
which we never were
always three months behind the month
ahead of gotten there
um but I'm working 95 hours a week
and
I need to stop that
so I need to figure out how
okay when you say you've got your budget
caught up your current on all of your
bills
I am okay do you have any money saved
no you have any debt
oh I do
I do how much
um
we owe I owe 22 000 on the car
and 44 000 on the house
and then
um there's about two thousand dollars in
miscellaneous things and what are you
making
right now I
I am 4400 a month okay cool
and do you have any money saved at all
no
no I figured no nothing with no life
insurance either I assume
no because we were losing our house so
we had to do away with life insurance
yeah
now you've gotten current on the house
are you in your current on the car
right yes
yeah okay have you done a detailed
written budget where you take 4 400 at
the top of the page and assign every one
of those dollars a number each month
before the month begins
yeah okay that's good very good
does that give you a real that must give
you a better sense of control than the
chaos you were living in
very much good yeah that was the only
thing I have control over uh it's really
the only thing I want control over yeah
and you but you've turned you've turned
this whole thing around in the worst
season of your life
what you've done is Herculean effort I'm
so proud of you they're very very
difficult to do what you've done
can you find
that they have done Financial Peace
University
um how long ago
several my husband was not on board in
any kind of way yeah how long ago did
you do FPU
um I think probably somewhere between
five and ten years ago okay I want you
to go back through as our gift
if I pay if I pay for it and give it to
you we go back through it
I'll do it yeah because that'll give you
you have a fresh new
um
because you you've worked so hard to
push the chaos to the side you've got a
freshness to your hope
in the middle of your grief and loss but
there's it's a weird sweet and sour
moment for you in that sense
but there's a freshness to your hope and
I so I think you'll see things in the
class and and learn things that you
didn't have the ability to see before
with the clouds does that make sense
yeah
I'll pay for it for you and you just go
through as our gift is there anything in
particular we can help you with today
how to
expedite getting
all of that taken care of meaning the
little 2000 my car
the house for that I can cut back I'm
doing two full-time jobs yeah awesome
part-time jobs well I mean the shortest
method is to clean the miscellaneous up
and sell the car
and move to a cheap five thousand dollar
car how old are you Karen
I'm 40.
okay you're 40
. and we had a May December marriage
that's fine I'm just making sure your
your phone is a little bit muffled now I
want to make sure I heard you I wasn't
questioning I just didn't know okay all
right good so here's another thing
that's going to happen you
um and I've sat with new widows who look
up and they say that what I think is one
of the most haunting questions
what do I do now I got to go to work
because there's no money in the house
and that's what you did and you've done
that first for four months now
and you're gonna have to let your foot
off the gas sometime in the near future
because you're running yourself into the
ground right
yeah when you do that you're gonna have
to feel what just happened
yeah and that's going to be terrifying
right if you've been able to run and
Sprint and run and Sprint to survive and
you haven't had to sit in
you lost the love of your life
so here's what I want to do if you'll
take me up on it my friends our friends
at betterhelp I'm Gonna Get You three to
six months of free counseling and you
can do it from your house on the on the
internet will you take me up on it if I
get that for you
yeah okay thank you it's going to give
you somebody to talk to completely for
free the better helps great friends and
so stay on the line and Jenna's gonna
hook you up with that as well yeah so
we'll put you in FPU and do that so we
walk with widows in a special way Karen
anything you need you call us we'll help
you out
um if you can hang on and pay off the
car that's fine if not if you need to
relieve faster the fastest way to do is
dump the thing so hang on General pick
up take care of you foreign
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thanks for being with us America common
sense for your dollars and cents
and for your life right here on the
Ramsey Show common sense is now so rare
in America that if you have it it's like
having a superpower open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Dr John deloney Ramsay personality
is my co-host today Brandon is next in
mayor whoa he's not there let me try
that I'm pushing the wrong buttons here
you know Dave you ought to learn how to
do radio all right Brandon is in
Baltimore Maryland hey Brandon what's up
hey uh not too much how are you today
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
Hey so uh my wife and I completed uh
paying off our debt about three years
ago and then following that she decided
to pursue her dream of writing writing
and uh trying to get traditionally
published
um and that was three years ago and to
this point she's still working on uh
finding an agent and getting published
and over the past I would say a year and
a half it's gotten tougher and tougher
for her and she's been battling a lot of
anxiety and depression over all of the
constant rejection that she gets in the
querying process and she has a very low
self-worth um
I do try to encourage her all the time
um that you know she's doing the right
thing and you know this is this is her
dream and it's going to be hard and all
of it's going to be worth it in the end
but uh all of the social pressures from
friends and family about her not working
and not bringing in any an income also
bring her bring herself worth down
so I'm really just trying to figure out
how I can help her
um how I can encourage her to to keep
pushing forward and what I can say that
might might help her through all of this
how how um just husband to husband how
honest can I be with you man
as honest as you want it's going to be
pretty direct
um yep unfortunately in an effort to
love her and really to keep her from
hurting in the moment
man it may not all work out
there's a there's a high high
statistical probability that she's never
able to get an agent
and even if she does get an Asian Dave
you you'll know the number of other me
but I think the average book sold the
United States is in the double digits
maybe the triple digits
and so
I mean I I'm a YouTuber for crying out
loud so I I'm all about Go For It Go For
It Go For It Go for it but there's also
a market reality and I know it's hard
because all the Hollywood movies tell
you there's this one guy that just you
know put all of his life savings into
this thing and then it all worked out
they just don't tell you about the
millions of people who did that and it
didn't work out
and so I think the greatest gift you
could give her is this notion of reality
and this come back to earth and this hey
let's let's put a deadline and agree to
agree that in three months by August 1st
by September one
let's sit down and not have a hard
conversation about if you're a good
writer I'm certain she's a good writer
not that you haven't written a great
book not that any number of things
but what's the deadline for how far
we're going to keep pushing on this
thing or what is she writing
uh she writes uh young adult uh fantasy
fiction novels
which is a very hot market and a very
very crowded market right yes yes very
much so what do you do
only with the US military for almost 10
years 90
000. okay and you said you guys were in
what kind of financial condition you you
got out of debt so she was able to do
this right
yes so how much do you have in savings
uh we have about three and a half months
in savings about thirteen thousand okay
all right so um it I don't think this is
what's going on but I want to say it out
loud so that everyone involved including
you doesn't accidentally let this be
what's going on okay we shifted about a
generation ago uh or almost maybe even
two generations ago to this idea that if
we told people how wonderful they are
that they are automatically wonderful
that if we told them they had high net
had high worth that they would believe
it and have high self-esteem when the
reality is is that high self-esteem
comes from the opposite of low
self-esteem comes from actually
achieving things
you get calluses you get some wins under
your belt if you're if you're a football
coach and you lose every game for six
seasons in a row you will have low
self-esteem
because you've lost every game something
is substandard in your football coaching
hello are the people you're coaching
there's some kind of a problem here this
that is systemic and so this idea that
somehow that now does that mean you're a
bad person does that mean we hate you no
it doesn't mean that but but what goes
with losing that much
it is
um is is you know
the struggle with self-image right and
so uh and and uh it's not to say that
you can't but but getting some calluses
getting some wins under your belt we'll
do that so I'm with John I I if I mean
I've published a whole bunch of books
I've done them with Publishers without
Publishers
um you know we are a publisher now we
publish John's books as an example best
sellers uh nothing in the genre that you
guys are in we don't have anything
fiction out there uh that's a wicked
weird different market for sure than the
one I'm in it sells a lot more books if
you get a hit but it but it's harder to
get a hit uh like my friend Brad Thor
who writes crime novels he sells 15
million on every book I've I've you know
I got one book that did over 10 million
right and I and I think I'm a big
success but every single one of those
Brad Thor Scott harvath books it goes 10
15 million copies it's it's wonderful
for him and I'm pissed off about it but
but that's what fiction is just a much
bigger Market than non-fiction so she's
in a good Market but it's also as John
it's a very thin market so if I were in
her shoes
I'd be looking for some wins or some
exits
and I would work this as a hobby while I
had something else so it would sound
like this we're going to get an agent
and a publisher by uh the close of this
calendar year or we're going to put
together some money and print 5000 of
these things and put it on Amazon and
try it self-published and you can go out
and and do readings at libraries and
coffee shops and try to get some young
get in front of some young adults in
some college classrooms or wherever your
Market is and get some people starting
to read it and a few people buying it
and see if you can get it to catch fire
and we'll self-publish it and we'll push
it out there but you're going to have to
we're going to do something rather than
sit and waiting on the roast duck to
come in we're going to leave with a gun
and shoot the freaking duck pluck the
duck and cook the duck so we're not
going to wait around anymore after the
first of the year and if you're not
willing to do that that's okay I
understand but this other plan is not
working it's killing you right before my
eyes and I love you and I'm not okay
with that
it definitely uh puts a little fire
under me you know and I'll tell you this
we want to see her succeed and
everything so I know you do I know you
do and you want her to be whole you want
to be happy you want to see her laughing
again and nobody
probably more than her you would you're
such a fan of hers you want her to have
a number one bestseller on the fiction
list and I'll totally get that
sometimes not even sometimes I would say
the majority of the time after three
years four years
it's the wife that tells the husband Hey
this invention's not gonna work
will you try something else or can we
try something else and it gives him if
he can finally drop his shoulders now
even if it even if you keep writing and
you keep putting it on the Shelf you got
to have a day job that's right but she's
getting some wins she might be so
relieved to hear you step in is what I'm
saying she may she may hate you maybe
hit you with with her manuscript that
could happen too you know what I think
it'd be better just blame it on me
it's my fault I'll take some too yeah
it's hard Dave and genre these two more
these two morons on this YouTuber show
yeah both of which have had number one
best-selling books but I like Dave I
like Dave's line that is really
important I'm watching my wife wither
away in front of me and I'll do whatever
it takes yeah because I love you that
much yeah you just tell her the truth
man that's the thing and but yeah
self-esteem does not magically appear
without some some success confidence
doesn't come just when you can't read
but you are good at self-esteem this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Matthew 13 16
but blessed are your eyes because they
see in your ears because they hear
Renee Brown said I don't have to chase
extraordinary moments to find happiness
it's right in front of me if I'm paying
attention and practicing gratitude denya
is with us in Charlotte North Carolina
hi Daniel welcome to the Ramsay show
hey hey what's up thank you for having
me
um
yeah I just
um I just have me and my husband
um I'm the 52 my husband's 54. we don't
have anything uh save for retirement and
I was trying as wanted
to possibly go back to school
nurse and if I went back to School my
income would go up
um
as an advanced nurse practitioner I was
that's what I was thinking of going
towards
um but we do have a lot of debt
um I don't know if it's practical at my
age and his age he was concerned about
that
it's a hundred percent practical to go
back to school it is a dreadful idea to
borrow money to do it
okay I have a hundred percent confidence
you could get through an MP program
please don't borrow money against it so
um
where do you work
um I work part-time in hospice or PRN
and also at a nursing home PRN I do a
few days a week with both of them
so I would check out some of the local
hospitals
and see if they will hire you and then
have an education program that pays for
your
NP
where you are they don't have that Ed
program
but a hospital would you work you work
as a registered nurse in a hospital
they'll pay for you to get your NP
a few years ago and the distance was the
issue
um and it is a graduate of
degree I don't know they'll pay for it
they want in peace
someone will or someone in corporate
medicine
will pay for an NP now they're not uh
they're not going to the nursing home
they're not going to a non-profit
they're not going to in hospice or a PRN
situation none of those that I've never
seen one of those that has a program
that pays for it but hospitals and large
doctor practices that are corporate
owned most of them have an education
program and would love to have their
registered nurses become in peace they
need them
gotcha I'll also tell you this it
doesn't hurt to ask where you are one
supervisor I went to at one point we
didn't have a program and I said hey I
really want to get this will you help me
with it and he said no but I'll send you
to Harvard so he sent me to Harvard for
a program then another boss I said hey
can I take this money and move it over
here for graduate school and she's like
I never even thought of that absolutely
go for it and that's how I got my second
degree paid for
and so it may be worth sitting down and
saying I'll go full time but I need some
help on this or here's what I want to do
can we all help me get there the worst I
can tell you is no and you're right back
in the same spot but they may surprise
you you may have to go to a full-time
gig somewhere to get that though I think
you have to go to a full-time gig
wherever you got two part-time gigs
right now right
yeah
yeah and you know you're making good
money uh probably possibly but you you
might make a little less money and have
them pay for your degree and uh do you
all own your home
we do we
win what is your husband
um he makes about 50. what do you make
yeah you're not working much
Richard nurse ought to be making 70 if
they're working 40. why aren't you
working that much
um well I just took a breather uh for a
little while here
um
I've just been home with myself and just
kind of taking care of stuff at home
what stuff is at home kids
how much debt have you got
how much is
his student loan that's 15 000 for my
bachelor's which I took out when I was
working at the hospital and they
required you guys need to sit down and
have some soul-searching conversations
didn't you because I've talked to two
different women on this phone
one of them was willing to lay it all
out on the line and go back to school
and go in debt to get a degree an
advanced degree as a nurse practitioner
so she can make more money to get out of
debt the other one isn't even working
much and doesn't do anything except sit
at home
these are two different women and I
talked to both of them in the last few
minutes did you hear me
I I understand the woman that I'm
talking to that doesn't want to work
much doesn't need to go back and get a
degree
is there something else going on
uh no I'm just you sound like you have
some heaviness in you like in your soul
you sound you sound exhausted but
exhausted spiritually
right
yeah I'm trying to figure that all out
[Music]
all right honey so the way we're gonna
get you out of debt is we're gonna get
your income way up but that's going to
involve a lot of hours
and I can get Hope from that if I'm you
because I can see that make instead of
making 35 I'm making 80 but I'm working
all the time and that extra 50 000 a
year is going to clean up this debt
really really fast and I'm not tired in
that situation I'm not exhausted I'm not
fatigued to where I can't breathe I
might be tired
but but it's a it's a good tired because
I'm getting traction and I can see the
light at the end of the tunnel that's
not an oncoming train if you can find
energy in the fact that you're going to
accomplish the goal and gear back up
then you can clear the debt and you can
start to make the moves towards nurse
practitioner the condition that you're
in today where you want to work just a
few hours a week there's no point in
going to be a nurse practitioner doesn't
serve any point
because you're not going to utilize the
extra degree to get any extra income and
I would not go to the expense or the
trouble to go get the degree and if
that's going to be your plan but I don't
think that's your plan I think that's
you've you've kind of surrendered
because you lost hope that you were ever
going to get out Dave and also sounds if
we had another hour to to sit with our
friend it almost sounds like if she
wrote home an extra fifty thousand
dollars her husband would have that
money spent before that check cashed and
she may just be saying I'm done like I
I'm I'm tired of not being on the same
page and so there's something about
sitting down and saying if we're gonna
get out of debt we're gonna do this
thing together yeah yeah the two of you
together sit down and say all right
we're both going to work an extreme
number of hours and we're both gonna
knock this out in 12 to 18 months and
then I'm gonna go get a nurse
practitioner degree and then we're gonna
go become wealthy only 52 and we have 15
years before 67. you could build
substantial wealth in 15 years if you
clear all the debt and you guys create
extra incomes uh increase your incomes
but simply going back to school as a an
escape mechanism is not going to work
uh we see a lot of people do that and
then they've got an escape mechanism
with a student loan attached to it and
this is a double dip in um
you know it's a double dip you don't you
just don't want to in bad things so
let's just not go there please please
please don't go borrow money and go back
to college right now no
be a bad idea man do sit down with your
husband and do say what if we were to
live on beans and rice what if I was to
pick up and double my hours what if you
doubled your hours what could we do how
fast can we get this done what do we
need to sell what do we got to do and
when are we going to grow up and be
responsible with money and I spend
everything we make so that we can retire
with some dignity because I'm tired of
being scared as a matter of fact I'm
exhausted from being scared
and let's step into that do that that's
going to make sense for you so hey hang
on we'll send you a copy of the book The
Total Money Makeover the two of you can
sit down and read it this weekend
together and it'd be life-changing if
you got on the same page there's
something really special that goes on
when you do that
Dr John deloney good hour thanks for
being with me
you got it man all right and Jenna Ben
James Zach and Andrew are all in the
booth making the show happen thanks guys
we appreciate you that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]